welcome everyone and thank you for
joining us for today's webinar
general informatics strategy for
specific scientific data from collection
to insight presented by dr. johan polti
a technical associate director Novartis
Institutes for biomedical research
my name is Xavier guitars and I will be
your moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots
labyrinth is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational no virtual events and
webinars now before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop down box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem
presentation is educational and thus
suffers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming dr. bull Tia I will
now turn the presentation over to him
Thank You Xavier good afternoon everyone
so today we're going to speak about how
we handle data at Novartis and while
working with particular scientific needs
just a brief overview of the agenda
first going to speak about my
organization how we approach data
management and why and I will finish by
speaking about architecture and data
mining goals
so for those
don't know Novartis is a pharmaceutical
company and Novartis Institute for
biomedical research is the research
branch of Novartis we have about 6,000
people worldwide across six campuses the
main one being in Basel Switzerland
Cambridge US and Shanghai China so I'm
currently located in Cambridge US we
collaborate across scientific and
organizational organizational boundaries
with a focus on new technologies to
produce gravity breakthrough for
patients so we focus lately a lot on
collaboration with academia and other
smaller companies to develop new ways to
interrupt cellular machinery causing
disease and the framework that President
Jeff Varner
put in place is as open source as
possible with open collaboration as
being the key word
so you can see on this NIH graphic the
drug discovery process for small
molecule and biologics from early
research on the top left corner to down
to clinical trial and marketing down at
the bottom of that graphics ad he lives
here that the font is very small so
don't worry too much about it what's
important is we focus on researcher and
targeted identification at an institute
here and you can see already on the
screen that there is some informatics
component to that research with data
mining data repository and bio
depository
so this is where but the organization
that I'm part of is as being the
scientist
we support the scientific community we
support them by providing an
infrastructure recently more and more in
the cloud we provide them with data
pipeline capabilities data integration
analytics and automation all these
really to help the drug discovery
process and facilitate the development
and deployment of application
so it's so obviously tempting to speak
about data science and machine learning
right away but before that the focus
remain on supporting the users and their
workflow it also forces to evaluate the
way vertical data the one generated by
the users but also the metadata from the
instrument and values device that are
being used at the in the organization or
the one we receive from external
partners flexi arrow in this pyramid in
this chart you can see a good old
presentation on the needs and dependency
we need to address before working with
the I it can be addressed for each
project for very specific needs but also
working at the organization level so it
really require initial work and this is
what I'm going to address today you can
see at the base of this pyramid that
collection of the data is the initial
step from instrumentation user data
sensors partners such as such as seals
and it can be as sophisticated as your
solution is and the data needs to be
captured and installed
the way you store it is relevant how do
you provide that data to your pipeline
where is it stored
do you need to transform it for example
do you need to normalize your data for
analysis and what kind of infrastructure
you need or want to have for your
particular type of data and you can see
as you going up in the pyramid you're
focusing first of the collection are to
store it add to explore the data and
finally you start addressing the
analytical needs with aggregation
optimization and finally ai
but before going all the way up to to
the top with deep learning machine
learning and AI technique you need to
are to have the bottom of the pyramid
this is by no means mandatory and it's
not always required depending on to do
but it is this is how we address it here
at Novartis and I decided to address the
data challenge what I speak but where we
want to go we still face many challenges
and I'm sure all the organization of the
same problem coming from years of legacy
data and less data centric world
organization at large is typically
organized around data so that's really
the first order that people encounter
you usually create silos around a
functional organization around the type
of application that you're using and
it's really difficult to walk cause
functionally
decision around the governance effect of
the data is also complicated people that
do the analysis might be the owner of
the data but the requester might be the
one to in analysis other you handle it
will really cause issues down the
pipeline if you decide to do data
analysis
infrastructure can also be very
difficult tools are not always the same
for all the teams depending on their
focus they will have different versions
different type of tool different
automation and it makes it really
difficult to share data across the
entire organization and of course people
have very different background this is
different aspect of a particular problem
and they usually focus on their own goal
rather than thinking globally about data
all these different challenges we are
facing now some of them are being
addressed and some will need to be
addressed later on
overall we spent a huge amount of time
and resources to really do simple
analysis it's a lot of manual step there
is no command ontology common vocabulary
across the organization so the way we do
analogies is not consistent not scalable
and there is really no way centralized
to share data in a simple way
the data being and all evil core
quite difficult because it's very
diverse in its nature you see here a few
example that I chose for the audience
the source of the data is different the
type of the data the size of it
everything is not structured correctly
you can see images here with the icon
and cleaning example animal data
registration of different type of
entities location of your sample of your
animals request tool and communication
with external partners for procurement
for example another case and of course
you have the pure scientific data
associated with each disease array our
noble scientists will not explain the
way they did the particular
electrophysiology experiment the same
way that cardiovascular specialists will
and this type of communication should be
addressed while walking on the way you
saw in the data
is a simple example in an enviable case
for example how we could collect data
very diverse type a source of
information tissue sample here will be
associated with a particular tumor model
that tumor model can come from an animal
that is chipped or as a battle these
sample relationship between the animal
the tumor model the tissue that you're
using for your experiment need to be
tracked and prepared after you track
that information will depend on our the
organization store the information and
while you're performing your experiment
you might want to have a particular ID
associated with let's say the antibodies
of the small molecule that you're using
on your animal or your tissue and the
data that you will have as an output of
that study will it be efficacy data or
pk/pd data will relate to that original
tumor model and tissue man tissue
management system that you're using in
the end it might be the scientists are
really doing the analysis of that
experiment or it might just all that
information into an electronic notebook
and an analyst will do some
visualization work for example here with
pod fire but it could be really any type
of other visualization tool
the example can cover the genomic or
proteomic profile of the the animal in
vitro data is to pathology data
biologics where is that antibody is
coming from for example where is the
animal coming from of the procurement
data the type of genotype and which
vendor did we use in the end of another
analyst you may want to have access to
all that information across the entire
pipeline of your experiment to make sure
that you're not making any mistake when
making a function and conclusion based
on that experiment
or that data are metadata in order to be
stuff according to its specificities the
data pipeline pipeline change depending
on the scientific workflow and then
stream operation can be applied to it
of course microscopy image for example
videos NGS data set they obviously have
an impact on the storage this very large
data set needs to be stored in specific
way and that should be considered in
terms of cost retention and access
at Novartis the current approach is
actually to implement datastore commonly
called data Lake as well we over provide
a data catalog that's used to register
and find the data easily and fast
security is present in terms of
authentication so who is accessing the
data and authorization who is actually
allowed to access the data and all this
is in the cloud right now to be scalable
based on demand from the users
exploration is the next step in that
pyramid that we saw earlier you need to
be able to clean the data curate it make
sure that you have a standard way of
describing the same properties and the
same metadata
defining that ontology is key and really
difficult it really requires scientific
knowledge and really subject matter
expert in a particular domain making
sure that when you're describing
property is associated with an enviable
sample in cardiovascular for example or
in oncology you're talking about the
same thing if they can be compared if
they cannot be compared then you have to
make sure that you're describing the
namespace or which type of data is
coming from oncology which one is coming
from cardiovascular
something that's coming up quite a lot
in the last 10 years is the third
principle data and supplementary
material have to have sufficiently rich
metadata and unique and persistent
identifiers to be findable that's really
key to find your data after storing it
and I do not mean right after the
experiment also mean in the next few
years when you want to be led to it
search to see somebody run a similar
experiment with the same type of
condition it has to be accessible
meaning that it has to be understandable
by human and machine it has to be
deposited in a trusted repository that's
really important
finally the last two points are a little
less important in terms of priorities
but they are very relevant to what we
want to do on top of the pyramid you
have to use a formal and shared and
broadly applicable language to present
your knowledge I'm going to speak a
little bit about the entity type catalog
on the next slide and that's really key
here to be able to share a common
language in terms of what you're
comparing the last point is reusable
data collection are we clear usage
lifeís and really provide accurate
information on the provenance of the
data that means that when you look at it
you have to be able to track down where
is that data coming from where is the
relationship between the different
samples and make sure that you can
relate the result to that data set
accurately
again adding an API meaning programmable
access to that data
allow the rest of the organization to
leverage specific
information and actually key to adoption
by you organization
I mentioned the entity type catalog
earlier this really allow you to
describe you data model accurately we
took a very simple approach by
describing everything either as a sample
of an object related to a protocol and
adding the data set as a result for
example this is a very simple individual
experiment where you have a sample e of
a presented in orange that sample have
to have an ID it is required for
particular activity as shown on the
right side it could be a type of assay
protocol instance and that sample that
could be is a molecule of protein plant
extract or so on produce a particular
data set it can be a result readout of a
particular instrumentation related to
that activity you see here in that
simple graph that the data set can be
directly linked back to the sample with
its own identifier and you can cover
more complex activities and model all
your scientific workflow in a very
consistent framework that allow you to
really compare apples to apple and
orange to oranges
in terms of Technology our current
solution is we need to build platform
and web services small micro services
apply to very specific needs that topped
with each other that way we can really
develop them really fast they are easy
to retire or replace especially upgrade
and depending on the need they are cheap
to maintain they can capture self data
if they have been they've been pulled on
that way and they really painless to
migrate from one type of web to another
type of enterprise back-end service that
common service layer can be used by
application that we develop inside the
informatic department but they can also
be used directly by the bioinformatician
that are embedded with the different
scientific team or by external
collaborators if needed
again that entity type catalog and for
the first principle and enforce the way
we describe each entity and their
relationship these relationships are key
to find sample associated with
particular data set and the relationship
between different type of sample think
again about the example of the tumor
model and the animal providing the tumor
model
back to really a little more information
about the architecture I realize here
the graph might be small but what's
important is you see on the right side
the application used by the users or the
bioinformatician in the middle here in
orange you see the service layer hosted
in the cloud in our case you have these
three main services managing activities
sample and result or data set and they
can communicate directly with the data
leg or the registration system while we
are identifiers from the sample and data
set photo desert the service layer can
then be interrogated directly by
bioinformatician or used by the
scientists for analysis in Spotfire or
such tool directly without having to
address the need to refine the
application so you can have very
specific application depending on the
need and if I take back the example on
ecology ecology and cardiovascular you
could have shortened an application for
cardiovascular during the same type of
information as oncology with a very
different user interface that could
depend on the type of automation they
use the type of experiment they use but
that service layer we interpret it as
the same type of information the same
type of data and store it in the same
way so one can compare these two
experiments with one another when it is
relevant all this without disturbing the
specific needs of each scientist
here I added this laptop at the bottom
showing that bioinformatician can
perform the analysis either directly on
the data set directly from the data leg
or can leverage the service layer
themself to look at relationship or try
to inter interrogate the data in a very
similar way as the scientist will do
what's important really here is to
support a scientific workflow that has
been the primary mission of the
informatics department from the
beginning while supporting their
instrument integration so we can
automate as much as possible we stopped
a challenge in use data really images
videos genomic data cleaning data I
screw put data on so forth
but we allow the user to visualize the
result and analyze their paper in a very
consistent way independently on the type
of data and what kind of instrument they
are using
the goal being to answer a scientific
question
the data is rich okay you have a Content
data and a notation additional be
limited by the current tools they want
to be able to assert a data directly
where it is table independently of our
destoyed and the analysis goes together
with the SA and the meta development so
depending what they want to store I will
store it we can make this search after
work independently of how it was done
upstream in the process
the main goal being to search and line
the day type cells across application
across disease area across labs and team
you want to search internal and external
data in the same way it doesn't matter
if it was if the experiment was
performed by a CFO or CMO or internally
that data should be stored in very
similar way internally and can be
searched by the scientist throughout the
organization that data is really rich
and important for the future of the
research
which should not be considered as only
silos of data according to the teams but
really as a global data source
and for this it's really important to
agree on an ontology and an architecture
how to access it
document everything having an API
available is really key for adoption by
bioinformatician and the rest of your IT
team
I will insist on that the UI on how the
application can be used the application
loop flag will help with adoption if the
scientists do not want to capture the
data and continue capturing it in excel
file or their own private tool that data
is lost to the rest of the organization
in remain in a silo so walking on all
the users interact with the application
and are based all the data is key to
success
you
I'll finish on speaking a little bit
about data management
to make to make it walk long-term you
really need to understand the type of
data you're dealing with that means that
you need to work with the scientists
with people in IT that understand the
type of data you're dealing with and how
to store it that scientific
understanding is key to store the data
correctly and to ask the population in
the EM the genetic architecture and how
you want to deploy that architecture is
key to make it generic and adopted by
the IP and by the bio information
community and the data model will help
you with that
finally data ingestion and integration
the project organization will allow
everybody to see the added value of
adding this generic architecture and
data management strategy
every time you add a new data source to
your existing architecture you will need
domain expert to help you understanding
the type of data you're dealing with its
size and so forth all this again to
address the base of the pyramid to
collect but then do stop up and the
Explo
understanding the scientific data and
understanding the scientific problem
would be necessary before going further
to answer the scientific question and
this you require multiple scale you
don't need only the ITU nonlinearly the
scientist you are you need to ask
collaboration between the two department
and you need to be able to speak the
same language with this I thank you for
your attention and I'm waiting for your
question thank you
Thank You dr. Padilla for that
informative presentation I would also
like to thank glabrous for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that this webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through May of 2019 as
a final reminder our speaker will follow
up with any questions you've submitted
being it's all for now thank you for
joining us and we hope to see you again
soon goodbye